everybody overthinks everything
everybody Ponder's everything like the
best strategy is to [ __ ] do not like
everybody [ __ ] debating cynicism Oh
Gary oh delivery Tino is asleep I should
I should sleep seven hours day good [ __ ]
face then [ __ ] execute in 17 hours
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you try so hard to make it birthday how
you guys do self 2013 sent back here
with Zack Nadler show Zack you guys
haven't seen that beautiful face before
but Zack is at CAA and books a lot of
speaking we've built a great
relationship
oh sorry Tina drove us Zack is my guy
and your boss we're [ __ ] Peter Jacobs
the sack is my guy anyway common and
here at a kind of morbid an economic
political kind of big hedge fund big
money gold screen of macroeconomics big
wigs like fancy people like Biden and
you know so pretty interesting I feel
like everybody who knows who I am will
probably three to eleven percent of the
people in the building right now know
that this is going to be an interesting
moment coming up because maybe I can
hear actually let me be quiet as we can
hear the tone and the energy to do this
stuff from before so we're not surprised
obviously people have their own styles
of communication and neural feel sad or
calm and but I'm going to bring a
totally different energy goal and then a
bunch of networking a bunch of internal
meetings had a couple of internal
meetings this morning to engage a VAR bx
portal ahsoka there are networks are
casement little big strap Menlo
opportunities here I'm excited about and
then met a red eyes the Canada one of us
we all of hours of sleep will work out
go to copy a couple meetings
and then home late tomorrow been a long
week
a lot of flooding realized when we were
talking about nine ten flights
I didn't realize made so many connecting
players export like gently Coulter
Kansas City Detroit Detroit to Ohio Ohio
to Dallas Dallas Vega really understood
both happening in this place and I was
lacking the represent 50% of the time of
an American on this device it takes far
more serious if the a she understood how
Facebook targeted as needs to election
or so the sweet if the understood that
remembers in five billion dollar market
for each event influencers or three
peoples or instances individual product
and cell mass scale if they understood
that was having a blast on stage with
retail is not only see you it's complete
beginning and anyway was construction at
retail but the okay Teresa's has written
were these were just here to share an
arrest low level of disruption that is
coming is exposing and in the short term
I really just generally don't know
emotions individual but in the short
term I promise you the incumbent that
doesn't think the level of Walmart and
Target being advocates in my head is
extreme the level of the biggest fashion
brands in the world the evidence is
extreme you know when I thought I think
about how horrible the nineteenth and
mother armors are because of cruel kids
on Instagram it sounds subtle Department
but anything that [ __ ] you in the end
centers funny you know you have seen the
long-term legacy
CEO that said screen wallpaper shorter
on an electric vehicles legacy because
I've made enough money and you've seen
what that means when you understand when
they looking part of Bezos and then with
the part Zuckerberg and they are related
on top of the Internet itself for
communication consumption you need to
understand suite that actually plays out
so please not be the business your
sixteen-year-old teenage girl to
behavior this is actually your behavior
you just haven't deployed it into your
business like yet because it's not a
good short-term financial interest thank
you 2013 is a young guy what a dink a
head out of you can me and my friends
believe but they never think I got
whatever javelin kids Activision copy
stepmother just I hate people consumer
and everything organ online learning I'm
always wondering like what's this media
like how do you choose what social media
Facebook will come before you guys so
much to say what you say what you want
you know like specifically his hard work
difference if it's 100 percent I think
you're always reverse engineering the
psychology of the end user right what I
love about Facebook those they're
spitting on such ungodly amounts of data
so the fact that I can go out so knowing
a lot about online learning the fact
that you can go after twenty to forty
one-year-old female single mom like I
know it's just so crazy right now and
what's happening is that Google's in 10
marketing product which is so amazing
the early two-thousands has gotten so
overpriced super competitive
but Rebecca everybody here in line is
vulnerable at the variable of the
creative if you don't actually get them
to give a [ __ ] when you got in front of
them it doesn't work but they on the
flip side if you get it right there's
Facebook's the only place where we can
have just do it or where's the beef or
MasterCard priceless and you can do it
for a hundredth of a price this
where do you see this going higher
education I think it's destructive I
think I think universities trade on
brand and they're starting to dilute it
with their online courses and what is it
what do they call these these mercs or
what's the term for eight-week courses
that kids are now running around saying
that they went to Harvard and Stanford
and I don't think Harvard and Stanford
and these organizations understand that
the only thing they actually have is
brand and that you actually as the
professor has the leverage and in a
twenty thirty year macro I think it to
be enormous ly disruptive recorder I
mean you still you've got a situation
where far majority people go after it
because of what they you know because of
what their parents think of what they
think yeah and as that continues to
dilute it gets I mean it's baffling to
me the emails I get from fifteen sixteen
year old like straight a hardcore
private school kids the the cracks are
in the foundation now macro economic
meltdown not as easy to be an
entrepreneur people you know but the
problem is what emerges from that I
actually think it is more cost-effective
it's just gonna be very interesting yeah
till a comic lot coming closer hey well
Jack Riley real pleasure Jack you I
worked briefly in New York where for
Adam run no kidding very briefly on pop
work very cool man I'm going to Ghana
next week - yeah very cool Mia that's
initially right you know I ready result
any rhythm yeah I just moved to LA so
one thousand five years Esther you
awesome in will pleasure
take care for a twenty one-year-old Rick
Sally here's the motivation it's real
simple there's only two core things you
need to be doing you need to be pulling
from opposite directions you need to be
patient as [ __ ] I mean patient you do
realize that thirty three you're still a
kid and number two you need to be doing
a ton of [ __ ] moving really fast trying
different things and figuring out like
what you're about period two very
opposite contradictions that will pretty
much create the biggest upside in a
framework of life
thank you a pleasure take care yourself
[Music]
let's do this interview with Yahoo and
you're happy because there's good light
thank you he was a good one for the
interview can we be on several
frequencies yeah I like sucks doesn't
come on yeah so much yeah that mean any
better thank you appreciate Gary thanks
for joining us thanks for having me okay
you were just in there giving your talk
yes rather touch my manager your hearing
your story on you're an immigrant I am
good the latest status is of the
American Dream today
I think it's massively alive and well
you know I think as a matter of fact I
think the internet being at scale today
has compounded the opportunity when I
see a lot of people who feel like the
political climate for example is
suppressing a female or a minority I
always try to remind them like look
that's the best time ever the internet
doesn't care what you look like
right you can go direct to consumer with
your offering
nobody needs to be in your way and so I
would I would argue that this is the
greatest time so much so that as an
early stage investor I've actually
stopped investing because everybody now
is a founder and a startup entrepreneur
and the supply and demand of actual good
operators has scared me so much and it's
a little bit of a guest game and I don't
know who's a real entrepreneur who's a
fake one but I would tell you that it is
extremely alive and well do you think
there's a lot of noise on social media
in terms of politics and how do you
navigate that I can't open my facebook
it's just politics on both sides I've
good news there's noise on politics on
television too like like when something
like the political climate goes extreme
it encompasses our environment I think
that socials are very easy you can
absolutely curate smaller lists on
Twitter you can create a non-political
list follow people I'm not doing a lot
of politics there's a lot of comedians
who are doing politics Jimmy Fallon's
not doing pot like you know
the reality is is that you have so much
control of your media consumption in a
environment the problem is 94% of people
are playing in that sector and if that's
not what you want then that's hard to
navigate to create your perfect list
Gary Vaynerchuk of vaynermedia thanks
for coming thanks for having me what is
the morning weekend my morning routine
is just like bathroom shower brush my
teeth I grab my phone right away make
sure there's no emergency my biggest
fear is something's going on in London
that I need to address as soon as I wake
up or something happen with a client
that I'm not in control of so first it's
it's intense it's like make sure
everything's okay then I kind of catch
up on my inbox and my social media so
within the first 30 minutes it's pretty
intensive like collecting data then I
work out and then I go to my first
breakfast meeting either at 8 o'clock or
9 o'clock in the morning self-awareness
empathy those are chemicals you may not
be gifted with that but the reason I
talk so much about hustle and hard work
is for everybody here it is
fundamentally controllable it's just
controllable it doesn't come natural to
everybody but working out didn't come
natural to me it was I was 38 years old
when I finally got my [ __ ] together a
little bit and started getting into
shape that's how I think about work
ethic maybe you grew up in a family
where nobody worked that hard you never
saw it you're 37 but you can change that
and I will always push hard work
[Music]
with a Gilligan I feel like I'm method
Gamble good yeah blur I can be I can be
sold on it okay I have a funny feeling
on number five please write it straight
up being raised good man
no indeed number five it's really crazy
I was five when I decided what my
favorite number was that's how it
happened I watched well Jarrod aha
listen I hope there's there's some
there's a prayer here
nope not a J don't be 28 that would
bother me
good the only two numbers I play are
five and 28 thank you brother
yeah that would open out a bother nature
AJ's birthday is January 28th I'm my
best when I'm combated like when I know
I'm walking into like I would be such a
great quarterback on the road there's a
different thing that happened to me when
I get into that black Honda machina you
know why I'm addicted to adversity it's
why I love the process it's why I love
the chip on my shoulder it's why I'm
winning everybody wants a good
everybody's a [ __ ] peacetime general
everybody just want to kind of do it and
have it awesome I wanted to be [ __ ] I
love adversity I like people booing I
like being a Jets fan exactly thank you
brother first of all my friend and my
buddy from college my confidence yes I'm
very aware of that he's the bad nominal
guy is that your buddy that's my buddy
that's amazing yeah like it's like
family to me it's discipline I saw him
so we will put the Wisconsin actually
that folks hanging up a lot of
investigators think staying a long day
on the phone sorry
take care I love your top thank you
brother great dude and obviously like
that me volunteering is experiencing you
or whatever no like I'm a big girl
inspiration perspective are two big
things for me glad you said perspective
I think uh inspiration I hear everyday
perspective I've rarely heard anybody
say appreciate that cause honestly I
think I'm doing a lot more perspective
packing that I'm doing inspirational I
owe you a one is the world in a binary
way of how it's going to play out
absolutely right yeah and tell you how
you do every single situation how you
react to it you know is everything if
I'm little bit it's a black and white
switch yeah really cool man be real
patients are going to love what she well
what is it what are we what what does
that mean help me I'm being serious I'm
in it now I'm committed all four of you
stop doing what you're doing I want all
four of you capable of doing it by the
end of vide middle next week well I
don't give a [ __ ] what you guys do your
big [ __ ] boys and girls I want all
four of you to be able to do it I want
it done ASAP Wednesday of next week the
four of you and if you tell me 98 other
people can do it smudges off I want a
second done I want to stop like a fake
bring it thank you babysit vacation look
at your faces now good to see you good
to see you when you go good see you okay
notice I could to see exotic a good to
see you Raj hello hello hello good to
see everybody just got off a really
interesting conversation with some core
people operator fired up speed process
cripples people we put process and
subject the creative but on a pedestal
following rules that just [ __ ] sucks
doesn't allow you to build
trillion-dollar things
and I think it's a huge mistake I think
it's a huge huge mistake and I'm not a
fan anyway what else going on
goodness ooh colleague Andrea great to
see you
any advice when you want to change
careers change them that's my [ __ ]
advice it's perfect timing
everybody overthinks everything
everybody Ponder's everything like the
best strategy is to [ __ ] do not like
everybody [ __ ] debating cynicism Oh
Gary uh delivery Tino is asleep I should
I should sleep seven hours day good [ __ ]
face then [ __ ] execute in 17 hours
just everybody cares about like all the
details and all these [ __ ] [ __ ] it
doesn't [ __ ] matter think about
[ __ ] changing careers change careers
like who gives a [ __ ] like that's it
like you don't need me I'm [ __ ]
Instagram live telling you to do it you
don't need your mom to do it you know
it's just we can do it like you can
afford it do it if you can't afford it I
can sell your house and [ __ ] rent an
apartment but if you're so [ __ ]
miserly once I can change careers change
careers [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody just
thinking about just [ __ ] do [ __ ] like
if I [ __ ] thought through everything
I've done in my life I wouldn't have
done anything none of it made sense hey
listen [ __ ] document everything and
then create micro content let's [ __ ]
invest in these [ __ ] companies and
nobody's ever [ __ ] heard of let's
[ __ ] sell wine on the internet like
[ __ ] do [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody [ __ ]
load whoops [ __ ] like really like it's
going to be a [ __ ] pose it's gonna be
a motivational post on my Instagram page
the [ __ ] lifestyle self-improvement
this a [ __ ] Oprah like [ __ ] like
God [ __ ] do [ __ ] I had no idea how to
measure EQ it's just people skills if
somebody's got it they have it I'm fired
up to double a part of Brooklyn alone
whatever Maddie your [ __ ] clown [ __ ]
you like you know little [ __ ] come see
me
[ __ ] Maddie Yankee come see me little
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm kidding Maddie I hope
you win I'm sorry do you think I'm a
clown but I hope you win
fired up today like just want people to
win like you know like I just want you
guys to do stuff
I miss you too Tyler baddest I really uh
hope you guys are well I just uh I just
want good for everybody by the way I do
have something I want to talk about
which is on the flip side I feel like
too many people that are building
audiences or have created some level of
success you got a verified account
you're an amazing founder like Lauren
Jim quick me like I think way too many
people are dismissing people that
disagree with them as haters or trolls
and I hate that I think it's massively
important to be empathetic
I think empathy is an enormous strength
in today's environment where everybody
has things to say and things that
they're to sense and I would really
really really implore the 4000 plus of
you that are watching right now to not
dismiss people that leave negative
comments obviously people like you're
you know derogatory terms or sexist
terms or just really dirty gnarly stuff
of course of course that's not a that's
not acceptable but people that are
pushing back and some of you have seen
some of the interactions that I've had
with people on the street that kid in
London or other places like I think it's
imperative to understand criticism but
it's also important for you to stay your
course like I hear criticism all the
time which i think is actually right if
you take a snapchat up today the problem
is I'm not playing for today my life is
not predicated on today and so I just uh
I'm just I'm really really really
looking for people to factor in a
people's feedback and not be as
dismissive and realize how powerful
empathy is how much is the foundation of
success
see ya what's the 1 micron reservation
with this video is that it's going to
hurt a lot of you in that sandbox base
rent control copy go with the DM and
start pasting and getting banned or
caused by Instagram followers looking a
bit post I want you to click Seen URL
and wait for that person to tell and
look at the website hello go ahead
document in life generally yeah I think
documenting is like journaling I think
obviously yeah sure I mean absolutely
like like you know like that today he
was a literally gear on their lives yeah
I mean uh I just think we have to put
out content speed and volume screen and
volume Facebook speed and volume that is
HUGE
that is HUGE you have to have speed and
you have the volume and the problem is
most people struggle with both and
that's why most people aren't successful
I mean like like the reason you're not
breaking out is two of the pillars
besides quality are speed and volume and
the third one is quality like if it's an
MC formula the formula is skiing
quantity quantity and quality that's it
and the third one you can't control like
not everybody's gonna be charismatic not
everybody's gonna be funny not
everyone's going to be attractive but
the other two you can if you break it
and and I'm struggling with so many
people are struggling without putting
out compelling content or they're
half-assing it because they're
overthinking their content and then that
means they're slow when you overthink
you slow down when you're slow somebody
passes you I mean do you know I don't
[ __ ] I [ __ ] just turn on this
Facebook live right now and I'm like
where we go like I don't know like what
do you think right Jason - like like I
don't know what I'm going to talk about
here like I'm just gonna talk about what
I'm living what I'm feeling were what
I'm doing how I'm going what I'm
thinking what I'm going I'm doing I want
you to go [ __ ] listen to me and work
and figure yourself out and get rid of
poison people in your life and put in
work and leave your [ __ ] excuses at
the door of poverty or broken homes
or or heritage or immigrant status or
skin color or gender I just want you to
leave them all at the door complete
mindset they're true I'm not dismissing
them they're true and I just want you to
think they're [ __ ] fake so you can
[ __ ] go
they're ready for us yeah I gotta go I
was in the middle good you [ __ ] up the
rock I could have been three minutes
late for that horseshit I wasn't you
need to know it I could see your face
you know guys it's the rock guys no
listen you guys admit it admit it admit
that the rock just directed MIT to
everybody that I was in it that I was
rolling that good [ __ ] was about to come
out and I know you're upset right
because you took something that was a
commodity which is like let's just be it
on time to something that means nothing
for three minutes
these guys I'm really sorry I ever get
yelled at but not me is there you're not
on sorry guys I'm sorry we got to go now
that's it I lost it I lost my mojo if
you're mad if you rock like I am let's
do this
d-roc we're going to do a d rock contest
and we go to rock what the [ __ ]
hashtag d rock what the [ __ ] get record
and turn this video positive you're
negative I'm going to turn into a
positive right now d rock there we go
guys it's right here take the screenshot
right now you give you a couple seconds
go over you're good lighting do you rock
you [ __ ] up you ruin the day alright
take a screenshot right now screen your
screen it screen it you know look aside
you know what to do when do contest
screen this screen this I'm giving you a
couple more seconds before setup screen
this screen shoot this right now
post on your on your Instagram this
hashtag do you rock what the [ __ ] I'm
going to I'm going to be one full minute
start taking screenshots use this you
rock what the [ __ ] hashtag in your post
and I'm gonna pick one of you and I'm
gonna fly you to New York City and
you're in a shadow d-roc for the day
which means you're shadowing me for
today everybody screen shoot right now
post this post this use the hashtag
d-roc what the [ __ ] so you're not coming
since right
[Music]
supporter what's going on here
the
a little rotational potentially saving
Jace's Guevara Jason's cavada they sell
April Jesus colada please sales premiere
for fruity telephone for the Africa what
is ever seen is that no nailing into the
dream a hand side I will make it rain to
my bin so I'm placing my dad at I see
it's not what would is whose heavy sound
off you couple hundred thousand abuse
since I've got many to have a glass slab
here miss Lou a brand new faces in place